[Music]
and one of my faculty colleagues says
you can tell the kind of class you're in
by the response if it's an undergraduate
class there's no response
they're still asleep if it's a group of
adults you get that kind of shout back
if it's a group of his graduate students
they write down the words good morning
for the two or three of you who don't
know me I'm bill Hecht and for the last
21 years it's been my privilege to be
your executive vice president now I have
done this for 21 years but four times
during that time are very special to me
because I'm a 1 and most of you are
sixes or ones so for the best bunch of
people the sixes and ones congratulate
yourselves
[Applause]
there is a small secret which I'll share
which is not a happy thought actually I
discovered not too many years after I
took this job that statistically I was
rapidly becoming an older alumnus I
tried to deny that for many years but as
you can see by the ribbon this is our
40th so I can't deny it much anymore
welcome to Saturday classes those of you
are youngsters don't understand that
this used to happen every Saturday
morning and we went usually to lab on
Saturday morning and worked very hard
over experiments which we were all
convinced that Michelson and Morley lied
that Milliken had oil in his glasses not
in his milk in his oil Drop experiment
but suffice it to say we all survived
and that's part of what MIT is about
surviving in style it's my great
privilege this morning to introduce you
to yet another spectacular technology
day program I must tell you a little
secret for 21 years at the end of this
program we say how in God's name are we
going to equal this year never mind be
better and each year the volunteers and
my staff with the great collaboration of
this unusual and rare and extraordinary
faculty seem to do better so it's my
great privilege to start the morning
proceedings by introducing my good
friend chuck fasst president of MIT
Thank You bill very much and good
morning to all of you welcome back to
Cambridge I think that we all know that
universities study and learn from the
past they have some level of engagement
in the future in the present and they
have something vaguely to do with the
future what really sets mit apart from
most institutions in my view is while
certainly we respect and indeed try to
learn a bit from the past we are really
among universities very deeply engaged
in the present and above all really
working very hard to invent the future
and another characteristic I think of
this institution is that we tend to be
involved with big important things and
to ask big important questions well
today we are going to tune this very
slightly and we're going to take a look
really into the very distant past as
well as the present in the future and we
certainly are not going to shy away from
big questions the program for today's
event was inspired by this highly
characteristic painting by Paul Gauguin
tropical paradise graced by stately
figures who somehow managed to look
simultaneously Moody and serene I've
seen those expressions around this
campus from time to time but there's
much more going on here than in bogans
customary renderings of Polynesian life
because he chose to use this panel to
pose some of the eternal questions in
its title where do we come from
what are we where are we going so you'll
notice that while Gauguin asks these
questions brilliantly his painting is
very careful not to actually provide the
answers it's a time-honored technique
though perhaps more typically reserved
for use on midterm exams
and of course these are questions that
genuinely resist being answered in any
simple or final or even definitive way
but today we're going to try anyway
this being MIT this morning we'll hear
from four outstanding scientists who
will share insights from their own
lifelong pursuit of great answers about
origins the origins very universe their
solar system and in the sense of
ourselves this afternoon three separate
panels will give us a chance to look
down the road towards some thrilling new
frontiers what we're learning about the
development of mind language vision and
understanding some startling new
materials and technologies that will
transform our lives and the latest
reports from the realm of exploration
from the depths of the ocean to outer
space
kogai of course was not the only artist
to consider fundamental questions of our
existence for the class that just
graduated yesterday the class of 2001
inevitably Stanley Kubrick's film 2001
has been sort of a mascot over the last
four years and in fact that film has
become such a cultural icon that it's
hard to remember that it itself was
based on Arthur C Clarke's wonderful
book but we've kind of forgotten what it
was really all about because for all of
its billing as a Space Odyssey
I think the deepest lessons is that the
simple truth that some of the most
important undiscovered territories are
to be found within us in the mysterious
recesses of our own hearts and minds
this morning we're going to examine both
ends of this spectrum of inquiring from
the sources of our universe and our
planets to the origins of humankind
right down to the level of our own
genome these are exciting times for
discovery and today promises to reflect
that excitement we're going to begin by
hearing from Eric Lander followed by
Canizares we will then take a brief
break following which we will hear from
Maria Zuber Stephen Jay Gould is
unfortunately not able to be with us as
planned this morning but he has asked us
to let you know that he very deeply
regrets not being with us
however we are really very fortunate to
be joined by one of Stephens colleagues
Charles R Marshall Charles will speak
after Maria professor Marshall we are
extremely grateful for your willingness
to join us on such exceedingly short
notice
and just to quantit since this is MIT
will quantify short notice
he's down putting his slides in the tray
right now following professor Marshalls
remarks we'll have a period for Question
and Answer back and forth between the
audience and our first and our speakers
let me begin by introducing the first
two speakers those who will speak prior
to the break Eric Landers professor
biology here at MIT and a member of the
Whitehead Institute for biomedical
research he's the director of the
Whitehead MIT Center for Genome Research
which as you may know was the largest
single contributor to the human genome
project last February that project
published a draft sequence and initial
analysis of the human genome the set of
DNA encoded instructions that define an
individual person before Eric begins I
want to tell you that we have something
here at MIT called campus preview
weekend this is a weekend in which we
invite all the young men and women who
have been admitted to MIT but have not
yet declared what university they will
attend and we had here in kreski this
spring a panel of MIT students so that
the prospective students could ask them
question and one of the first questions
one of these high school students held
up her hand and said can you people
somehow characterize what's it like to
be at MIT what's good what's bad
and a hand immediately shot up and said
the defining moment of my time here at
MIT was when Eric Lander spoke it to us
all in room 10 250 about the final
publication of the sequence of the
sequence of the human genome that really
characterized what this place is all
about and I think we would all agree
with that our second speaker this
morning is Claude Canizares Bruno Rossi
professor of experimental physics at MIT
and director of the Center for Space
Research Claude is also associate
director of NASA's Chandra x-ray
Observatory Center and leads the
development of Chander's high-energy
transmission grating spectrometer just
one of his many space astronomy missions
well eric is in a sense an expert on
inner space Claude's focuses clearly on
the far reaches of outer space he's a
specialist in both x-ray and optical
Astronomy meaning that he studies stars
galaxies clusters of galaxies quasars
and other things which give us important
clues to the structure evolution history
of the universe we begin with Eric
Lander
thanks very much Chuck well welcome to
this day about origins and beyond I'm
gonna start us off by talking about a
variety of kinds of biological origins
origins of life origins of human
populations origins of cancers all of
which our knowledge about emerges from
the work of the human genome project
over the course of the last ten years
there's another important origin that
runs throughout all of what I'm gonna
say which is that the origin of an awful
lot of the Human Genome Project and the
data that's come out of it is here at
MIT MIT is woven completely into all of
this project both the intellectual ideas
that got it started the tremendous
amount of work that got it that got it
done and particularly the
multidisciplinary approaches involving
biology computer science and engineering
that made it possible for it to happen
here in a way that I think it couldn't
have happened
anyplace else so let's talk about
origins for thousands of years humans
have recognized the tremendous diversity
in our own species and in the species
around us this is my favorite picture to
illustrate diversity will Chamberlain
and Willie shoemaker here showing the
wonderful diversity in our own species
with respect to height and weight and
skin color and to me it's also
emblematic of the differences that you
don't see in differences of
susceptibility to diabetes and
hypertension and and cancer all of which
are underlined by the action of genes
working together with environment but of
course for thousands and thousands of
years we could do a little more than say
the traits tended to transmit in
families and we really didn't understand
the origin of this transmission well the
major breakthrough historically was the
work of Gregor Mendel in 1865 when he
published his one great classic paper
indicating that there were these
abstract particles that he could infer
called genes that were transmitted in
according to species
laws of inheritance in crosses now as
you may or may not know Gregor Mendel's
paper is a wonderful paper but it's sank
like a stone it had no impact on its
world on the world at all because the
world just wasn't ready for it
Mendel perhaps somewhat discouraged
really never wrote much more about
genetics and in fact went into
administration and that's pretty much
the last QE he became the abbot of the
monastery in any case the real
revolution of genetics dates from about
thirty five years later in the opening
weeks of the 20th century in January of
the year 1900 three independent groups
around the world rediscovered Mendel's
laws so to speak they went back and they
they started doing crosses they began to
see these regularities and then they
pulled out this paper and recognized
what its tremendous tremendous
importance was and so the 20th century
started with a bang with the
understanding that there were laws that
somehow contained the controlled traits
the first quarter of the 20th century
was spent pinning down those laws to a
cellular structure by about 1925 we had
a pretty good handle that the cellular
origin of these abstract laws were in
the chromosomes of course we didn't have
a clue what the chromosomes did
chromosome just the word chromosome
itself is a tribute to the scientific
ability to cover up ignorant with a
fancy name the only the only thing that
we note with that was really known about
the structure of chromosomes then was
that they picked up a dye when you
stained the cells and so they were
called chromosomes meaning colored
things it took it took another 25 years
to work out what these colored things
really were and by mid-century we were
able to determine that the chromosomes
had as their molecular basis the DNA
double helix the work of Watson and
Crick these this iconic double helical
image with information running on one
strand and a redundant copy on the other
strand of course this didn't tell us how
in an information theory sense heredity
was encoded in this polymer but the next
25 years
spends working out the genetic code the
understanding of how the sequence of
bases encoded messages which went off to
little factories in the cell that turned
them into proteins through a process of
translation according to a genetic code
as well as the tools of a recombinant
DNA including very prominently here in
Cambridge and these tools of recombinant
DNA let us do what the cell does that is
to say copy and readout particular
pieces of DNA and even modify those
pieces so we got two about 1975 now with
an ability to read some DNA sequence
well the last quarter of a century has
been a time of raesha Sapa tight to read
everything we can get our hands on it
started with a reading of individual
genes here and there then more and more
genes than small genomes the entire
collections of genes in an organism -
somewhat larger genomes - by the end of
the 20th century a first pass reading of
the entire genome of the human being at
3 billion letters it's not bad for a
century to have gone from a recognition
of abstract laws to essentially a
comprehensive readout of the 3 billion
letters underlying that it's a pretty
good century although I think we ain't
seen nothing yet in the last 10 years 10
or 15 years of that century it began to
become clear that we could use this kind
of information about genetic sequence to
take a systematic approach to
understanding disease now all through
the 20th century people worked on
disease and in some cases they were very
lucky and were able to get to the basis
of a disease but as you well know luck
is something you can't count on any
particular day when you go into the lab
far better would be to have a systematic
approach that you could apply to every
disease regardless of its type whether
it was brain degeneration or bowel
irritation you would like to have a
common approach well that approach was
first laid out here at MIT in about 1980
the notion was a very simple notion that
if you traced the inheritance pattern of
a disease in a family you could see that
the disease appeared to be transmitted
according to Mendel's laws
you could just find a piece of DNA which
had a spelling difference that seemed to
have the same pattern of transmission
then although that piece of DNA might
not be the cause of the disease well it
must live fairly close by and that is
indeed this notion of genetic mapping
that was laid out for the human being
around 1980 or so and became operational
here in Cambridge in the mid 1980s and
it led to the identification of many
many particular disease genes once you
found a marker that was nearby of course
you don't have the gene itself what you
have is a long work ahead of you in fact
you have to go through a very tedious
process called chromosome walking or
more formally although we don't call it
in the literature chromosome slapping
where you would you would start with a
marker and then you would schlep along
the chromosome because it's incredibly
tedious using one piece of DNA to get
the next piece the next piece the next
piece the next piece is the next piece
and then four years later and 40 million
dollars later you might arrive at the
gene of interest say cystic fibrosis on
human chromosome number seven well
here's the sequence of the cystic
fibrosis gene it's got a lot of letters
it doesn't look very impressive but I've
boxed for you one particular little
feature over there I'd better blow that
up there we go those three letters CT T
those three letters are deleted in the
majority of chromosomes with cystic
fibrosis about 2/3 percent of the
population will carry that particular
deletion and in fact on the way out the
door if we wanted to everyone could spit
in a test tube and enough buccal cells
would come off from the inside of your
cheek to have enough DNA that we could
just take it back across the street to
the lab amplify it and tell you if you
were a carrier for that deletion you
don't have cystic fibrosis unless you
have a double dose but we could tell you
if you were a heterozygous carrier well
not just that we can't not just DNA
diagnostics emerge from that but even
more emerges one can toss the sequence
of the cystic fibrosis gene into a
computer and ask the computer ever seen
anything like this before and the
computer says oh yeah this looks an
awful lot like doesn
dozens of genes whose products sit at
the surface of the cell and transport
things back and forth congratulations
you've just found a transporter now this
of course stood on its head the usual
way of doing biology the usual way is
when you make a discovery you go back to
the lab and you spend years and years
trying to figure out what this gene does
now you spend a couple of seconds
hitting the Return button and the
computer more often than not comes back
to you and tells you what your gene does
because somebody's somewhere else in the
world and some other organism has
studied something sufficiently similar
that you have a pretty good guess that
kind of hypothesis generation by
connecting all of biological knowledge
has led to a dramatic explosion of
research because in the old days all
bits of biological research were
separate from each other now they've all
been interconnected through this common
lingua franca of sequence well the big
problem with all this was that it was
extremely tedious it took four years 40
million dollars about 200 people to get
this cystic fibrosis gene out and as we
all know the productive unit of science
is the single smart graduate student or
postdoc and they're not going to sign up
for something like this this is not a
good project and so the job was to lower
the activation barrier to level the
barriers to actually doing this to
create the infrastructure so that a
single graduate student or postdoc would
be limited only by her or his ideas not
by the huge amount of work that was
needed but that meant we had to engage
in big science work to build
infrastructure in the service of that
graduate student imposed that and so it
was born the Human Genome Project the
idea that we would build genetic maps of
polymorphic markers up and down the
chromosomes that would let us trace
inheritance physical maps of the
overlapping pieces of DNA so we wouldn't
have to engage in chromosome schlepping
but we could just go to the shelf and
pull down the relevant piece of DNA
sequence maps so we wouldn't spend years
sequencing out the DNA from a region to
find the gene but we would just
double-click on the region and
annotations of all those genes in a
description of all those genes so that
when one found the gene one would have a
pretty good guess of what it did at the
time we expected to have about a hundred
thousand genes or so as I'll tell you
it appears that we have rather less well
more poetically what the project was
about was building for biology what the
chemists had in the course of the 20th
century a periodic table the chemists
had a periodic table from about eight
different about 1869 to 1889 following
Mendeleev ski insight the chemists put
together a periodic table that described
all of matter in terms of about a
hundred building blocks those building
blocks were understood their
relationships were summarized in these
rows and columns of the periodic table
giving rise to the chemical industry
giving rise to quantum mechanics to
explain all this the variance on these
elements the isotopes were understood
and this is of course the basis of all
of chemistry biology is now at the point
where it's putting together its periodic
table there are just a finite number of
genes may sound like a big number tens
of thousands 30,000 genes but that's a
pretty small number these days we will
in relatively short order know them all
in pretty good detail know all their
variation know what they do and the
biology students a decade or so from now
we'll start with a pretty good periodic
table of all the components now how was
all this done well from about 1985 when
a human genome project was first
conceived of in 1990 when it was
actually launched we needed to make just
dramatic changes in the way biology was
done traditionally the way you would
sequence DNA was you would clone the DNA
in the little piece in a bacterial cell
you'd grow up the bacterial cell on a
Petri plate you'd take a toothpick you'd
pick it you'd inoculate a culture it
would grow overnight so you had enough
without that bacterial colony with that
one piece of DNA
you'd centrifuge it down you would use
organic reagents to crack it oh you use
reagents to crack it open and organic
solvents to be able to separate the
protein from the DNA then you'd said oh
god it was just terrible and really slow
and it was done one at a time with
pipettes so a big concern in the period
1985 to 1990 about the human genome
project was would we consign an entire
generation
of graduate students to some kind of
servitude sequencing DNA was this gonna
be deadly boring there was talk about
doing this in criminal instituted penal
facilities
you know sentencing people to ten
megabases
with time off for accuracy
well it didn't turn out that way and it
didn't turn out that way because biology
met engineering and so just a couple of
blocks away from here you're at MIT
genome Center this is the equivalent of
the toothpick the toothpick now is
represented by Robotics that run round
the clock they have cameras on them that
identify where the colonies are ninety
six pins that go and pick the colonies
dunk them into media wash themselves
bake themselves go pick ninety-six more
etc and we pick a hundred and ten
thousand distinct bacterial colonies a
day and all that a person has to do is
put the plates on and walk away we don't
have to purify all of these DNA is set
up sequencing reactions etc instead of
the army of people standing around with
pipettes it looks like this this is the
way we do mini preps for DNA and this is
very much unlike a biology lab ten years
ago what you see here a factory style
conveyor belts with microtiter plates
moving around the laboratory at a pulse
rate of one per minute 110,000 of these
items being processed through the
laboratory all the way from DNA
purification through the setup and
cleanup of a sequencing reaction once
all of that biochemistry is done we have
to put them through detectors there the
commercial world has served us well by
developing detector machines that we can
use we have a form of these sequencing
sequence detectors we put on ten plates
on each sequence detector walk away and
it runs 24 hours unattended all told
this this whole operation I've described
you the actual number of people involved
in managing the workflow there is under
about a dozen and a half people managing
all of that workflow at the end of the
day this machines this suite of machines
turn out about 65 million letters of DNA
sequence per day this is just a
tremendous
explosion of information at the height
of the human genome project the the rate
of sequencing was a thousand letters of
new sequence every second as best I can
tell I don't have the accurate actual
numbers but as best I can estimate I
think that rate has actually doubled
since then despite the fact that the
human genome project is no longer in its
the height of the frenzy so much
capacity has been in place that I think
I think the rate is continuing to go up
well all of this led to a dramatic
explosion the sequencing of the human
genome was first piloted format 1996 to
1999 that pilot period was when we
worked out all this robotics all the
biological technologies to be sure that
we could cover the sequence of genomes
etc we then had scheduled and have been
scheduled for quite some time they
ramped up in the spring of 99 to try to
take on the sequencing of the genome and
lo and behold everything was ready for
it the ramped up was launched and in the
course of about 12 months we went from
having about 10 percent of the genome
covered to having nearly 90 percent of
the human genome covered it looked
something like this
that was the sequencing of the human
genome or the course that month and was
just well I mean I just love looking at
that picture there and living we'll do
that again I was just so much fun there
we go how does that genome getting
filled I don't know to me there's a lot
there was a lot of pain underlying that
picture but it sort of like childbirth
or something in retrospect it's really
just fun to look to think about there in
any case the product justifies it this
was the product not just of MIT of
course it was the product of an
international consortium of 20 different
groups around the laboratory and the
world indeed MIT was the largest
contributor to this effort we
contributed something in the
neighborhood about 30% of the total
sequence and it really was quite a quite
a big effort here but there were also
large centers in England the Sanger
Center in Cambridge England and also at
Washington University in st. Louis but I
think it was equally important that
there were laboratories in many other
countries of many different sizes that
contributed to this the United States in
the UK and France and Germany in Japan
and even in
chyna the group in China joined in late
but but the group in Beit but that group
in Beijing did a marvelous job they
contributed one and a half percent of
the sequence of the human and what it
said clearly was that the human genome
was indeed the patrimony of all of
humankind and appropriately it was
worked out by a large international
consortium the only criterion for
signing up for the human genome project
you had agreed to make all of your data
immediately and freely available on the
web as soon as it was assembled within
24 hours of assembling the data it went
up on the web no restrictions whatsoever
all the groups signed up for it and I
think it was a wonderful thing that they
did because it meant that when we with
that people could immediately start
using this information when we went to
write a paper about the sequence of the
human genome well usually people have to
speculate in their paper about what the
consequences of their work will be we
had the absolute joy of being able to
devote a section of our paper to how our
data had already been used to find
disease genes and that was just a very
satisfying aspect to it
so anyway this whole Human Genome
Project got a fair amount of attention
there was lots of hoopla in the press
and there was some several visits down
to Washington some celebrations down in
the White House and things but to the
scientific community the only thing that
really matters is a peer-reviewed
scientific paper and that occurred in
February with the publication of the
largest paper in the history for the
journal Nature on the initial sequencing
and analysis of the human genome it
actually was written as a friendly paper
and even if you're not a biologist or
haven't touched biology in a long time
you might want to pick up the paper
because there are whole chunks of it
that really were intended to be friendly
enough to be readable there are other
bits eul's you want to skip over but
that'll they'll be obvious so just skip
them over I'm not gonna try to tell you
everything that's in this human genome
but I'll mention a few interesting
things particularly with regard to
origins interpreting the sequence of the
genome we have a fold out to this
sequence of the human genome it's
actually two entire Center folds on both
sides this is just chromosome number 11
here that I'm demonstrating and you'll
see the gene distribution and many other
features you can't really see the
details but I'll call your attention
there is some gene rich regions and some
gene poor regions she enriched gene poor
gene poor gene rich and interestingly
this correlates with the visible banding
patterns of the chromosome this is part
of a dark band on the chromosome this is
a light band on the chromosome dark band
light band so even sitting way back
there in the bleachers you can see that
there's a correlation between banding
pattern and gene density and if your
eyes really good you'll even see that
there's a correlation between low gene
density and a low proportion of GS and
C's in the sequences compared to A's and
T's anyway there are many gross
interesting features that are visible
with this high level of view well of
course this is not a very good view to
take because well at least as it appears
in the journal the scale is about 3
million DNA letters per centimeter which
you have to have really good visual
acuity to appreciate and so instead
there are a number of genome browsers
freely available genome browsers that
you just find on the web just just just
look at you can look to the University
of California Santa Cruz the National
Center for Biotechnology information to
the European bioinformatics Institute
lots of cooperating genome browsers are
there where you can zoom in by factors
of 10 all the way down to the base and
up all the way to the chromosome you can
scroll over you can see whatever
annotations you want or hide those you
don't want and it's a wonderful thing
that we now have a number of these
freely available browsers that let you
inspect the genome I'll mention just one
or two facts about the genome they're
kind of fun most of your genome does not
consist of genes fact genes are only
about one and a half percent of your
genome most of your genome consists of
repetitive elements that are autonomous
replicating elements that copy
themselves and on evolutionary
timescales move around your genome they
hop around so if this is your genome
here half of it is filled with these
repetitive elements who are interested
only in their own reproduction they make
copies of themselves into RNA those
copies are copied back into DNA and they
get slammed into the chromosome see
there we go they get pushed right into
the chromosome there and and over the
course of time they account for
half of your total sequence now it's
very interesting about these repeat
elements is whenever they hop whenever
they do this they go one they bring with
it the sequence of the ancestral
elements from which the copy was made
but when they land there they're usually
broken and so they begin to build up
mutations that means they're a
historical relic and we can tell how old
they are by how much they've built up
mutations in fact we can tell whether
two copies of this repeated element are
cousins or close brothers that were born
at the same time because they have the
same distinctive sequence
characteristics in fact we can build an
entire phylogenetic tree relating the
origins of all of these repeated
elements in your genome to tell which
ones are part of a sip ship that hopped
a million years ago or dispersed
themselves 20 million years ago or as
far back as 800 million years ago all of
that is there so you are chromosomes we
now realize are a geological record
there are all sorts of geological
fossils about 3 million geological
fossils all of which have dates on them
from that we can for example tell just
the simplest thing what the rate of this
transposition has been over the course
of time if we go all the way back
reaching back beyond 1/2 ability half a
billion years about 3/4 of a billion
years the rate was sort of constant it
shot up around 75 million years ago and
then interestingly the rate at which
these elements have been hopping around
our genome has plummeted in the last 30
million years this is a major ecological
you know I'll change we don't understand
what's happened why of these things
stopped hopping this by the way has
consequences
since this accounts for half your genome
this means that in the long run our
genomes are getting gonna get smaller
because there's a deletion process
that's though that deletes these and if
you're not replacing them the
equilibrium size the genomes gonna get
smaller now
don't worry too much about it cuz the
time constant on this is
long the rate of deletion the rate of
deletion of useless DNA is about well we
house clean our useless DNA with a
half-life of about 800 million years so
this effect will kick in in the next
several billion years or so so but
nothing there too excited about but it
is very interesting biologically because
this fact I'm telling you is not true
about the mouse in the mouse it appears
that the rate of transposition has
continued just fine it's something
different between the hominid lineage
and the rodent lineage and if I had time
I tell you about a population genetic
hypothesis that explains it in terms of
the effective population size of
hominids versus rodents but we're
understanding now first off the origin
of half of our genome and a fascinating
dynamic process of these elements well
there's much else you can tell about the
genome by following these passive
evolutionary markers that are said are
just conveniently scattered across but I
won't tell you about that I'll describe
briefly the genes there's a lot we can
tell about origins from the genes
themselves there was a great effort in
this paper to try to do the best job we
could of gene identification it's by no
means absolutely complete but I think
the vast majority have been identified
and the first surprise was there are a
lot fewer genes than we had thought
indeed I have apologies due to some
members of the audience I have been
lying to the 701 students in the intro
bio students for the past 10 years by
teaching them that there are a hundred
thousand genes in the human genome I'm
trying to send that notes to all of them
and and make sure that we're we correct
this but it appears that there really
are only 35,000 genes in the genome the
hundred thousand number when we closely
checked the literature a it turns out to
be a back-of-the-envelope estimate that
had really huge error bars that somehow
everybody just latched onto and b in any
case the hundred thousand estimate was
due to a colleague at harvard
so the genes tend to these genes are
very interesting they bunch up in these
gc-rich regions they have more splicing
or we have more alternative splicing
alternative ways to splice and dice our
genes and gene transcripts then happen
in flies and worms and things what but
when we actually look at the origins of
humans we should ask our our proteins
very different than other organisms in
terms of the modules they're made up of
and the answer is no maybe 5% or so of
the protein modules the little
architectural domains that make up our
proteins are innovations amongst
vertebrates 95% of them were there
before vertebrates so what's new about
us well the origin of vertebrates seems
to have more to do with innovation in
architectures rather than in the domains
themselves by architectures I mean ways
of combining the domains in new
combinations but existing domains so in
point of fact our creativity that gave
rise to the vertebrates is somewhat
derivative it's mixing and matching of
pre-existing parts in a sense it's not
that surprising of course because these
pre-existing parts you know back in the
primary were Toulouse you had time to
evolve a new domain and it didn't have
to work so well but as life filled up
more and more than niches on this planet
it was necessary in order to compete
that a new gene pretty much worked from
the get-go and therefore had to be made
out of pre-existing components and we
didn't see that very clearly in our DNA
that that seems to be the basis of
vertebrate novelty in addition the the
simplest way to make novel genes is just
to duplicate a pre-existing gene and let
it change slightly highly derivative but
very effective and this has been the
basis for example for such things as
smell receptors you have in your genome
a thousand smell receptors indicating
that vertebrates were very interested in
smell the origin of vertebrates has a
lot to do with smell then I'm
fortunately I have to tell you that you
have largely decide
despite your ancestors interest in smell
that you're not so interested in smell
hominids have largely gotten have
largely let these smell receptors go to
seed about two-thirds of your smell
receptor genes are broken they have stop
codon so they no longer work that is not
true about a mouse mice are much more
interested in smell they keep their
smell receptor genes in fine working
order
we seem to have put all this energy into
making smell receptors and then we've
let them break in favor of site as a
preferred sense for for humans all of
this you can tell from the genome there
are stories about origins and changes
throughout the genome well anyway back I
can't tell you all of the wonderful
things in the sequence of the genome
there's so much to say about what's in
there but what I can tell you is that
it's just the start we went into the
human genome project thinking that we
had to build infrastructure in the form
of maps and sequences in order to let
people really do their work in order so
that people would be limited only by
their ideas we've come to understand
that the work of building infrastructure
has only just begun there is a
tremendous amount of work still to go I
want to just highlight some of the areas
in which that's going on comparative
genomics to really understand the
sequence of the human to understand
medicine to understand origins we need
to be able to compare the human sequence
with many other organisms to see what
evolution is kept and what it's changed
we need to have comprehensive
descriptions of each gene in terms of
where it's expressed in the body and
when it's expressed in health and in
disease and during development we need
to know the shape of every one of the
proteins so called structural genomics
we need to have a chemical that
interacts with and binds to and inhibits
where possible every protein we need to
have diseases classified in terms of the
sets of genes that are turned on and off
and we need to have a comprehensive
description of the variation in the
human population
all of these are giving rise to genomes
style projects of their own to lay the
groundwork for that graduate student and
postdoc of the future I'll just touch
very briefly on where all this is going
just to give you a sense of the world
that is starting if you thought the
Human Genome Project was something just
wait for the next decade of what's going
to explode the mouse a year ago we had
very little sequence of the mouse maybe
about 1% as of today about three fold
random coverage the mouse has already
been generated it covers about 90% to
the entire genome it's freely available
on the web and it's been integrated with
the human sequence by matching them up
in fact 2/3 of this entire project was
done here at MIT and it is leading to a
tremendous amount of work on mammalian
genomics it's important because by
lining up mouse and human we can see the
conservation of elements and we can spot
things that we might have missed with
our computer program for example if we
ran a computer program over the human
genome to identify genes we have a
signal to noise problem genes are only a
little bit of the overall sequence by
lining up the human and the mouse
together and running a computer program
over both simultaneously we can kind of
do a kind of coincidence detection
almost in a genomic interferometry of
some sort where we ask do we see
features present in both genomes and we
get tremendously higher sensitivity and
specificity to identify genes and not
just genes but what's popping out are
things that we had never had a way to
see before regulatory elements the don't
encode proteins but encode the
instructions to turn on here at a
certain time we recognize because of
conservation between mouse and human
there is of course work on many other
species in the course of the past year
we sequenced a very important and
largest fungus studied Norris pura a
very important genetic organism and this
was just a great example we got a grant
from the National a three-year grant
from the National Science Foundation to
sequence Norris pura and we completed 99
and a half percent of the Norris bird
genome in the first two weeks of that
grant the last half a percent will take
a while I admit because and then
there'll be time spent analyzing it but
the success of this project here at MIT
has led to a consortium of fungal
geneticists to identify 15 different
organisms that they want to study
representing important medical fungi
commercial fungi and fungi that will
shed light on evolution and diversity
and so we are hoping if we
the funding to do this to basically
start a fungus of the Month Club
starting later this year a model
vertebrates tetra Odin
a pufferfish the sequence of this
pufferfish is being generated in Paris
and here at MIT and already about
threefold coverage of this organism is
available this seemingly unimpressive
filter feeder a tunic it called ciona it
just sits there in filter feeds
why bother sequencing it well it turns
out it has a brief period in its life
when it is a tadpole and it has a
complete coordinate body plan with a
nodal cord and all the structures in a
tiny genome and so we began sequencing
this this beast a few weeks ago we've
already got one fold coverage of its
genome and we expect to have about ten
fold coverage of its genome this year
onward and onward genome sequences will
come spewing out similarly comparisons
amongst human beings there is a
tremendous amount of sequence in the
human genome this is sequence but
there's not that much variation that's
the variation if you can't see that I'll
circle that for you there we go
those were the two spots of variation
that's it one base in 1,300 is the
extent of variation in the genome it
turns out that this makes perfect sense
from some dusty old formulas of
population genetics little populations
have a little bit of variation we're
actually a very little population
although we're six billion people today
we were ten thousand people in Africa a
mere several thousand generations ago
and that signature of a little bit of
variation a few thousand generations ago
has persisted because a few thousand
generations isn't enough time to build
up more variation so as a consequence of
that we'd predict that most genes should
only have two or three flavors in the
population and when we look that's
exactly right
most genes have only a few flavors that
has led to a very exciting idea that
every gene has its isotopes a few
isotopes and that we could correlate
disease with the variance or the
isotopes this common disease common
variant notion is I think becoming very
important
know some examples april lipoprotein ii
it comes in three flavors lives on
chromosome 19 eetu 3e4
if you have a double dose of e4 you have
a high lifetime risk of Alzheimer's
disease we know a few other examples
like that but our goal is to identify
each and every one of the variants for
each and every one of the genes that is
the common variants and correlate them
with all major traits and while this
seemed like an absolutely nutty idea
even five years ago I think folks are
conceding that this is very likely to
happen certainly over the next decade
and it may be that we have all this
variation characterized much sooner than
that
indeed the goal was to detect disease
genes using lots of variants there are
two different ways to do it I won't fuss
over them we started with a paper here
at MIT about three years ago where we
reported 4,000 variants in the human
genome we thought that was a lot at the
time of course it now is a puny number
but what it did was that particular
paper got the world interested in
generating these variants and an
international consortium was put
together in parallel with the human and
it led to the generation of 1.4 to
million variants across the human genome
and this paper was published in parallel
with the human sequence paper back in
February this again was a wonderful
international consortium and again it
was a consortium led here at MIT with
about half of all of this work having
come from MIT with it we're now studying
the nature of these ancestral segments
and populations and it's it's really
quite a remarkable thing the segments
that we're looking for they're big they
have a limited number of forms and I
believe we are going to be able to get
comprehensive descriptions of all of the
ancestral types of all of the genes and
I think that this will form the basis of
a new kind of human genetics I'm going
to skip through a bunch of slides that
just say that in some detail and come to
the end and say what we are getting is a
global perspective on biology we started
with a comprehensive project to generate
complete sequence and now we're
realizing we also have to generate a lot
of other complete things complete
descriptions of where genes are
expressed what their very age
are what the structures of the proteins
are what the cell circuitry looks like
and how we're gonna clip the wires it is
an extraordinary decade of building
ahead and it's going to transform the
way we take on biological problems it is
going to give us our periodic table we
already have it in rudimentary form
today but nowhere near as well annotated
as we need to have we will spend I think
here at MIT there's there are projects
leading many of these efforts we will
spend a lot of time generating these
data but we have also spent we will also
learn one other thing from this and that
is some lessons about how to do science
I think biology was in a very different
state in 1985 than it is today back in
1985 biology was done almost entirely at
the lab bench in small groups with
people who focused on single problems
usually with single skill sets what the
human genome project has forced us to
confront in biology is something that of
course has long been known for physics
and for chemistry and for engineering
which is that we too need to work in
multidisciplinary collaboration that we
need to be able to work in larger teams
with professionals that of course
graduate students and postdocs are
always the backbone of creation and
invention but in order to be able to get
our work done we have to be able to put
together teamwork we need to build
international cooperation on many of
these projects most dramatically I think
for understanding human populations we
need to engage the human population and
we've also learned that the traditional
model of holding on to your data until
you have published is not a necessity we
can in fact make all of our data
available as we're generating it all of
this is leading to I think restructuring
and rethinking in biomedical research
and I think it is time to think about
new kinds of organizations new kinds of
institutions to take on the challenges
of biomedical research of course these
are new kinds for the typical medical
school out there or a biology department
these are not new kinds to places like
MIT where we have long appreciated the
importance of multidisciplinary
collaboration of teamwork of putting
together
efforts that are larger than any one
individual can do and so my own
expectation is MIT has a huge role to
play
organizationally in showing the
biological world how we can combine
biology with mathematics with computer
science with engineering with chemistry
in a new kind of biological and
biomedical program well its traditional
to end any talk by giving a list of the
names of all the people who participated
that's going to be difficult in this
case this was truly quite a remarkable
project and if we mean not just the
sequencing of the genome but all these
other things I've been talking about it
would take part far too long to be able
to run through the names there are on
the web actually we for the Human Genome
Project try got everybody's name who's
involved with it on the web but I do
want to show one picture here of the
group here at MIT at the light at MIT
Center for Genome Research that did the
work here and led so much of the effort
on sequencing and on human variation and
on many other aspects I haven't talked
about it's really just been a tremendous
tremendous privilege to work with such
an extraordinary group of colleagues
here at this institution but I should
also put up this credit slide here this
was an example of a project and a whole
field I think that could only have
gotten done through the joint efforts of
an entire world working together and I
think we're all tremendously proud of
what was accomplished by all pulling
together in one cause it's great to tell
you about the origins of life the
origins of humans the origins of disease
and the origins of the human genome
project what a great fun technology day
today thanks very much for coming
[Applause]
many of you I'm sure have seen the
wonderful short film produced many years
ago by Charles Eames and mi t--'s own
film arson that starts with a still
photograph of a man lying on the on a
blanket after a picnic on a summer day
and then zooms alternately down deep
into the skin of his hand showing first
the skin then cells then atoms and then
turns around and goes out into the
universe showing the solar system the
planets the galaxies and beyond this
journey today is something like that one
as shown by Charles Eames in film arson
but the difference is that whereas
whereas they were talking about a static
picture of the structure of these huge
differences in scales what we're talking
about today is an even more difficult
question and that is the dynamics of how
this all came about how is it that
there's great complexity and diversity
which Eric showed so beautifully in the
area of the genome and organisms but
also exists for stars and planets and
galaxies how could this great complexity
and diversity emerge from what we know
to have been an extraordinarily uniform
and intensely hot Big Bang that began
some thirteen billion years ago and
furthermore how is it that this great
complexity and diversity seems to have
emerged on each scale almost as quickly
as the laws of physics would allow of
course we don't have anything like a
complete answer to those questions but
you know this entire range of scales and
you've certainly seen it for America in
the case of the genome we've made we're
in the midst of a tremendous revolution
in our understanding about the origin of
the universe from its very beginnings to
the genome in the last few decades
in fact most of this has been in the
last 20 years since I think bill hex 20
is reunion that cosmology has gone from
a science that used to be well described
by the words of Mark Twain a wholesale
return of conjecture from a trifling
investment of fact but the new tools of
the last 20 years have changed this
completely and I have the pleasure of
sharing just a bit of this with you
today the the tools that the ones that
I'm particularly involved in I'll show
you in a moment but I have to say that
this has been matched the observational
detail which I will focus on has been
matched by an equally extraordinary
advance in our theoretical understanding
and our ability to do numerical
computations thanks to Moore's law so
that we can advance our our deep
understanding as well as our catalog of
observations well to show you the tools
of the trade first of course one of the
the most extraordinary has been the
Hubble Space Telescope and this has been
a major contributor I'll show you lots
of images from Hubble I'm particularly
proud of the mission that truck vests
mentioned initially the Chandra x-ray
Observatory because half of the
scientific instrumentation for this was
built here at MIT and we're deeply
involved in using this to probe the
universe and also although a lot of what
I do and what Maria will tell you about
is done from space there's a lot to be
done on the ground and using modern
telescopes and we're very happy that MIT
and its partners dedicated last December
the first of two large research
telescopes in Chile the Magellan
telescopes which are now being used in
this as well
so let's now start our journey out into
space and back in time to look at some
of the things that we've learned about
the origin of the universe we're
starting on earth of course the
the home planet and and it's interesting
that completely independently Eric used
this image of the earth which is up in
the upper corner in case you don't
recognize it the earth is one of nine
planets there are only eight if you live
in Manhattan near the Museum of Natural
History but and and that must be where
this slide comes from because they left
Pluto off the slide - but professor
zubur is going to tell you a lot about
the origin of the planet so I'm going to
move fairly quickly out beyond them but
one of the major discoveries of the past
decade has been the existence of some
two dozen or more ordinary stars that
themselves have planets orbiting around
them this is the culmination of
literally decades if not centuries of
speculation about whether or not our
solar system is unique and we know now
that it is not the detection of those
systems is is made indirectly by
observing the wobble of the parent star
as the planet tugs on it during the
orbit going back and forth around the
planet and we haven't yet been able to
make a picture of a planet around
another star but the Hubble telescope
and I'm sorry if we could I don't know
if there's a way to reduce the glare on
the screen if there is I would from the
lights I would appreciate it this shows
a picture taken with the Hubble
telescope here's a bright star this
streak is just the artifact of the way
the telescope is constructed it is in
focus and this dot here is not quite a
planet it's sort of somewhere in between
a planet and a very small star but it is
orbiting and it's the closest we've come
so far to a direct picture so it's
called a brown dwarf but nASA has plans
now in the scientific community for an
observatory which could well fly
sometime within the next one to two
decades to try to actually image planets
around other stars of course what we
want to learn about is the process by
which the planets formed and again
professor Zuber will tell
a lot more about that but I I want to
start with this and then she will end up
moving downward I'm gonna start moving
outward in a moment but this shows one
of Hubble's very famous and beautiful
pictures of a region in our galaxy it's
a stellar nursery in which gas and dust
is coming together from the from the
Milky Way our parent galaxy and to form
new stars and it's the as those stars
form they begin to burn their nuclear
material on the inside they they light
up and then that radiation ends up
pushing on and illuminating and and
pushing around the clouds of gas that
have yet to form into other stars this
these contorted columns are are very
beautiful but they're also the
indication of where stellar birth and
planetary formation are taking place you
can see this very clearly here in this
picture which shows the same region of
space here it is just tilted to orient
it in the right direction from its
Hubble picture this is a picture taken
with infrared radiation from the ground
and you can even see here the the sort
of hint of the shadow of these columns
but the infrared radiation penetrates
the the dust and so you can actually see
inside to where the young stars are
forming it is the molecular hydrogen and
other elements that are that are
condensing in these clouds to form the
stars now the many of the stars that
that form in these systems show the kind
of evidence for formation of planetary
systems that had been theorized for many
years but now we can actually see in
much more detail this shows four
examples from the Hubble telescope of
young stars so-called protostars there's
in various stages of having of igniting
themselves and they're backlit by the
other radiation scattering off the
the those columns I was showing you this
is actually a different nebula but it's
the same phenomenon and you can see the
shadow that's cast by a disk of material
at the center of which the star has
collapsed
but this remaining disk of material is
where planets will eventually we think
condense and to make planetary systems
not necessarily that different from
those from that we know here in this in
the solar system well it may surprise
you to learn that in addition to stellar
birth stellar death is just as important
to understanding the origin of the
universe and the origin of life as
stellar birth is the early universe we
have excellent evidence essentially
consisted of just hydrogen and helium
and maybe a tiny bit of other very light
elements that were formed just a couple
of seconds into the Big Bang barely a
trace of any of the elements certainly
no carbon nitrogen oxygen the kinds of
things that that we need for life there
all the rest of the chemical elements so
far as we know has to be synthesized
have to be synthesized in the interiors
of stars through the nuclear processes
that make them shine but then they
remain locked there until the star
releases them to eventually mix in and
become one of those clouds that I just
showed you before one of those nebula
from which new stars and planets can
eventually form it's a cosmic case of
ashes to ashes and dust to dust
without which certainly life wouldn't
would never have been possible some of
the way the the most of the ejection
takes place is that some fraction of the
stars when they reach the end of their
lives explode in a massive explosion
essentially turning themselves inside
out and returning all this newly
synthesized chemical material out to
interstellar space and we see the
process of that happening a
here is a patch of the sky visible only
from the southern hemisphere actually it
looks at for those of you familiar with
this a small dwarf neighbor galaxy of
ours called the Large Magellanic Cloud
in 1987 that patch of sky suddenly
looked like this a star that had reached
the end of its normal life exploded in a
massive explosion ejecting the chemical
elements that had synthesized in its
interior during these explosions for
about a few weeks after the explosion
takes place a single star can outshine
an entire galaxy this shows the same
region that same star about a dozen
years later in the late I think this is
around 1999 but this was taken there's a
ring of material this is sort of a clump
in the in the middle rings of material
illuminated by the radiation and the
shockwave that that that passed out that
is streaming out into space and and by
studying these we can study how the how
this process of returning of the
material to the interstellar matter to
make new stars takes place the Chandra
x-ray Observatory is particularly well
suited for studies like this because as
the material flies out it gets heated to
very high temperatures about typically
10 to 100 million degrees when it
radiates x-rays and those x-rays can be
detected by our Chandra telescope the
this shows the such a remnant now a
similar ring but now this is of a star
that exploded some 350 years ago sighted
around 1650 by the astronomer Flamsteed
and the colors we can analyze the the
x-ray signal to actually do a chemical
analysis of the material that's been
ejected and this is almost entirely this
is about 20 times the amount of material
that's in the Sun and it's almost
entirely silicon sulfur and iron and
other such elements that were not
present in the Big Bang but were
synthesized inside the star and those of
you with sharp vision can see
a little knot in the center that is we
think is either a neutron star or a
black hole that was left at the core
when the star exploded and it's another
interesting object but there is no time
unfortunately to tell you about that the
this sequence of stellar birth and
stellar death and regeneration and
returning of the chemical elements for
to make new stars takes place in a
neighborhood and the neighborhood is the
galaxy our own galaxy the Milky Way is
an is a spiral shaped system not unlike
this one this is our neighbor the
Andromeda nebula a spy it's spiral
shaped system of stars flattened
containing about a hundred billion stars
I noticed that another similarity
between studying the cosmos and studying
the genes is that we like to take
numbers there are about a hundred
billion stars and maybe a hundred
thousand light years across now let me
remind you that a light year is actually
a astronomers unit of distance it's the
distance that you would travel in a if
you travel at the speed of light for a
whole year and that's about five
trillion miles the these galaxies are
this is another one these galaxies are
the sites and which stellar birth and
death and takes place and planetary
systems form and you can see here for
example this bright spot in this spiral
galaxy is expanded here in a Hubble
picture to show a nebula not too
different from the Eagle Nebula the one
with the columns that I showed you
earlier the universe we now know is
teeming with such galaxies a very long
observation with the Hubble Space
Telescope of a patch of sky where
previous observations showed that there
was hardly anything there so that so
that you wouldn't be bothered by
anything so bright that you could see it
with a normal telescope
the Hubble stared at this patch of sky
for something like a week and took a
very very long exposure what it
uncovered is a remarkable diversity of
galaxies each one of these things is
like a Milky Way with a hundred billion
stars we found that there are something
like a hundred billion galaxies probably
in the part of the universe that we can
receive signals from the visible
universe in a rich variety of shapes and
colors the other thing about looking at
very distant galaxies is because of the
finite speed of light when you look at a
distant galaxy you're seeing light that
was emitted a very long time ago because
it's had to travel so long to get to us
so for example in this picture there are
three galaxies shown this one the light
was emitted a billion years ago so we're
seeing what galaxies look like a billion
years before I remind you that the
interesting scale is that the age of the
universe is about thirteen billion years
this one was about four-and-a-half
billion years ago when the about the
time the earth and solar system formed
that's when the light left that that
galaxy and arrived at the Hubble Space
Telescope sometime a couple of years ago
and then this this little funny thing is
the galaxy that's just forming it
doesn't even look like a normal simple
galaxy and the light was emitted over
ten billion years ago so this is a
record as a historical record of a
different sort than the one that that
Eric mentioned but but just as useful in
astronomy for understanding how galaxies
form and looking backward into the early
part of the evolution of the universe
now galaxies themselves are not randomly
scattered throughout the universe but
they tend to congregate kind of like
people they they're often bound together
in groups and sometimes even great
clusters of galaxies that contain
thousands of hundreds to even thousands
of galaxies and cover fill regions of
space that are several million
light-years across these are the largest
gravitationally bound system
in the universe now again to contrast
this picture in visible light that shows
the galaxies with x-ray astronomy it was
discovered that in addition to the
individual galaxies there are the entire
space between those galaxies remember
we're talking about a hundred million
light years across now here is filled
with a very diffuse gas that glows in
x-ray radiation the interesting thing is
that this discovery showed that there's
actually three or four times more gas
more matter in the hot gas than there is
in all the stars in all the galaxies but
the other thing that came out was even
more surprising and it was a
confirmation of suppositions from
earlier work in optical Astronomy and
that is that there must be something
more there than the galaxies and the gas
that in fact the total amount of matter
required to hold this entire assemblage
together and keep it from flying apart
into space requires something like 10
times more matter now this matter is
something of a still of a puzzle but
we're so we're sort of zeroing in on it
it's often called dark matter just
because it's dark we can't see it but we
know it's there because otherwise the
gravity simply wouldn't be so strong and
so it's most plausible right now to
attribute this to some kind of exotic
particle it cannot be normal matter we
know it can't be no neutrons protons
electrons it cannot be the same sort of
stuff we see around us or that we see
even in stars it has to be something
different and the most likely place that
astronomers look as to our colleagues in
particle physics to eventually discover
some new exotic particle that will
explain this in the meantime though it's
evidence is very very clear here is
another cluster of galaxies and you see
these funny blue wispy things on the
outside though although all pretty much
all the other sort of yellowish things
are galaxies and you can see there's
this is actually quite a dense cluster
so there's a lot of them there it's a
lot of matter
these blue things are actually more
distant galaxies much more distant than
the cluster and the reason that they
look distorted and that you can see them
at all since there's so much more
distance is that the gravity of this
cluster primarily the dark matter in
that cluster bends the light acting like
literally like a gravitational lens or
one could call it a cosmic telescope and
magnifying the background galaxies so we
have ample evidence that the dark matter
exists there's really at this point I
think no question that that is the case
something that's a little more
controversial but is now becoming more
and more widely accepted is that the
universe also contains another thing
that we don't understand very much of it
all called dark energy this dark energy
actually acts like a repulsive force in
the expansion of the universe and it may
be that our universe is just about to
enter a new accelerating phase of
expansion thanks to its presence that is
something which is is very new and and
still the subject of very active study
well let's move to an even larger scale
this picture doesn't do justice to what
I'm going to describe it is a map of
galaxies in a region of space that's
probably about a hundred million light
years across and their entire clusters
of galaxies sort of lost in this thing
these are not gravitationally bound
structures rather they're a dynamic
motion of galaxies and clusters of
galaxies that are not again spread
uniformly over the sky is one might
think but tend to congregate in these
filaments and and structures separated
by large regions where there's very
little going on and the size of this
region on the sky as I said is several
tens of millions of light years these
entire dance of galaxies and clusters
slowly in the universe is the formation
of structure it's it's the thing that's
happening thanks to the Big Bang
material along in certain regions was
enough to condense to make stars in
galaxies in other places that simply
didn't happen and nothing formed even
about this very early and largest scale
we're getting some new information and
the information is coming by studying
these galaxies and clusters themselves
but also going back even further to look
at what we can get from the Big Bang
itself the when when the universe was
about two hundred thousand years old
after the Big Bang which as I remind you
was thirteen billion years ago so just
very shortly after the explosion on a
cosmic timescale radiation matter became
neutral and all the radiation that then
had been generated before that it was a
sea of radiation and matter at that
point the radiation simply streamed out
into space we are still detecting that
now and it's the so-called cosmic
microwave background radiation it's in
the microwave region of the spectrum it
was actually first detected by accident
by a couple of Bell Telephone engineers
in New Jersey and in in in the early 60s
and the the measurement of that
radiation has actually been a goldmine
of information about the earliest
moments in the universe two hundred
thousand years that's as early as we can
get after the Big Bang so far what we
find is really remarkable consider this
paradox you and I and planet Earth and
this plant are lumps of matter that are
some thirty orders of magnitude denser
than the mean density of the universe
around us that's ten to the power 30 yet
in its infancy by looking at this
radiation we can see that the universe
was ending in exquisitely uniform and an
homogeneous broth of matter and energy
with with no differentiations of bubbles
or lumps that were bigger than ten parts
per million it is the tiny ripples which
now have been measured from several
space experiments and now most recently
from high-altitude balloon
these tiny ripples this is a map of the
sky in this radiation but with it but at
a very tiny level the the ripples are of
the order of one one thousandth of 1%
ripples on top of a uniform radiation
these ripples from the early edge of the
the the Big Bang so to speak are the
seeds from which all galaxies all stars
all planets and all genomes eventually
emerged the ripples appear in a in
addition to confirming a lot of the
theories and this is this slide is a
very poor attempt that I think came out
of National Geographic to pick the
entire span of the universe this is the
Big Bang it doesn't look too impressive
does it and what we're talking about is
how we went from this very smooth
aftermath of the Big Bang to suddenly
make galaxies as the cartoon shows I
think with the toothed physicist
standing at the blackboard with their
equations and then there's a line that
says and then a miracle happens but we
don't think it's a miracle but we do
think but but but we do think that it's
in fact easy it is something which is
calculable and which we are trying to
get a handle on that these tiny seeds
that occurred here one one thousandth of
1% eventually made the galaxies and the
stars now there's something even more
remarkable which I'll only be able to
mention in passing but if you want to
ask questions about it later I'll do my
best and that is that these observations
now are also confirming the fact that in
the very earliest moments of the Big
Bang there was an extraordinarily period
of rapid expansion the inventor and
pioneer of this is right here at MIT
Alan Guth and it's called the
inflationary universe theory and it is a
theory which has to be Alan Greenspan's
worst nightmare because in that in a
moment in in in a tiny instant of time
10 to the minus 35 seconds after the
after the initial event that caused the
Big Bang the the universe expanded by
some 30 orders of
magnitude and then continued on with
it's by comparison relatively gentle
expansion that we still see going on
today what's even more remarkable about
the theory of in the inflationary
universe theory is that it says that
this entire process could have been
started by a tiny seed and that in fact
all of the matter and energy of the
universe could be created out of that
tiny seed and that is what Alan Guth
often calls the ultimate free lunch well
speaking of lunch I've whisked you out
to the edge of the universe and back to
the beginning of time but I guess it's
time to come back to the home planet and
have coffee go guys wonderful painting
and some of the remarks that Chuck vest
made speak to the age-old quest to
understand our origins we certainly
aren't anywhere near to having answers
to all the questions but one of the
things that's been most fun for me is to
see simultaneously from the level of the
genome through to the understanding the
inflation and that occurred in 10 to the
minus 35 seconds after the Big Bang
we've made extraordinary progress in the
last few decades and we're just poised
on the verge of making a whole lot more
so thank you very much for the
opportunity to tell you about this
you